dès le 7 février il ne restera plus que
la voiture ou l'avion pour se déplacer à
l'est de rimouski
keolis canada suspense et services
d'autocar orléans express ce pour une
période indéterminée
la loire et mauvais traitements andré
ouellette qui a l'habitude de prendre
l'autocar une fois par mois se demande
ce billet sera son dernier
dès lors que allait voler qui décroît
pas le mental n'est parfait relais alors
que marc marquez n'a de préférer les
faire cuire en payant ça m'enrage
littéralement chédigny francine rossi
travail auprès de personnes vulnérables
c'est un service essentiel les personnes
âgées là qui n'ont plus leur permis de
conduire qui ont rendez-vous à québec
qui vont voir leurs enfants montréal
5h30 taxi pour se rendre à rimouski le
gouvernement vraiment affaire à agir
parce que si toutes les entreprises qui
disent qu'ils ont perdu de l'argent
pandémies font ça on va fermer la région
c'est tout mais pour keolis canada la
baisse importante du nombre de passagers
en raison de la pandémie lui a forcé la
main
et si on veut être là la sortie de
pandémie pour pouvoir servir nos clients
là il faut prendre des décisions
difficiles puisque on perd des millions
par mois
la compagnie avait déjà signifié son
intérêt de réduire ses services en
gaspésie bien avant la pandémie
elle avait même eu le feu vert de la
commission des transports du québec
mais l'énergie gaspésienne avait décidé
de lui verser 35 mille dollars par année
pour maintenir une desserte par tout en
gaspésie et à keolis a discuté avec le
gouvernement et de nos pôles d'utiliser
les élus comme un moyen de pression
politique pour obtenir ce qu'ils veulent
au niveau du gouvernement
mais on a aidé parce que d'autres
problèmes de transport interrégions
depuis un an et françois bonnardel
devrait être en mesure d'annoncer des
bonnes nouvelles bientôt le ministre
québécois des transports à françois
bonnardel n'accordera pas d'entrevue sur
le sujet mais surtout at-il expliqué que
son gouvernement est en action pour
trouver une solution à court terme comme
ce fut le cas pour le transport aérien
en région à la suite du départ d'air
canada
ici martèle le gua radio-canada gaspé